[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
au sport à la culture et aux droits vous
savez que c'est bientôt les les Jeux
Olympiques dont beaucoup d'épres se
dérouleront dans les ivelines et à cette
occasion et bien l'université de
versailles- Saint-Quentin a organisé un
colloque sur le thème du sport et du
droit avec des sujets absolument
passionnants sur le sport et la sécurité
le sport à la religion mais aussi les
les implications géopolitiques du du
sport on va y revenir avec Anis kobinski
bonjour bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférence au droit privé à l'vsq vous
étiez une des organisatrices de de ce
col qui a eu lieu au Château de versaill
hein c'est ça trique le 11 janvier tout
à fait absolument éc aabou bonjour
bonjour euh vous êtes professeur de de
médecine vous êtes neurologue
euh l'fr Simon Veil et vous êtes aussi
alors vous vous êtes aussi à l'hôpital
vraiment Point Carré hein si on veut
prendre rendez-vous je dis ça pour
ça plaisir et vous êtes vous êtes aussi
chargé de mission euh pour les Jeux
Olympiques et Paralympiques à
l'université de versailles- saint-contin
alors vous nous expliquerez pourquoi he
l'université sex s'occupe de sport et
d'ellivolf bonjour bonjour Patrice vous
êtes maître de conférence de droits
public à l'université de versailles-
Saint-Quentin visoyen et chargé de
mission culture à l'université euh là
aussi euh bah la culture entre comme ça
dans l'université
en sort aussi parfoisum et et et vous
nous expliquerez les les liens de la
culture du sport justement et justement
peut-être avant de d'aborder les thèmes
que vous avez abordé dans dans le
cololloc Erric azabou je vous êtes donc
chargé de mission pour les pour les Jeux
Olympiques euh c'est vrai que c'est
assez nouveau au fond que le le
l'université s'occupe de sport
non tout à fait c'est pas si nouveau que
ça l'université a toujours euh c'est
toujours intéressé au sport mais là avec
l'avèement des Jos ça prend une autre
proportion euh parce que en dehors du
fait que l'université vu sa proximité
avec les étudiants euh et son ses
missions d'enseignement de transmission
l'université a assez rapidement
identifier euh une un positionnement qui
lui permet Mme de faire circuler un peu
plus les valeurs du SP auprès des jeunes
surtout que comme vous le savez après
les le confinement les crises la crise
sanitaire même le le taux de sidentarité
des étudiants qui étaient déjà élevés
mais c'est accru encore et donc c'est
vraiment l'occasion de remettre la place
du sport dans l'université pour euh
voilà euh motiver les étudiants à la
pratique sportive pour à la fois leur
santé mais aussi la réussite parce que
vous savez le sport c'est aussi un
vecteur de la réussite c'est vrai que le
le les les liens du sport et de la santé
ils sont très forts au fond
tout à fait en fait on y pense pas au
quotidien mais en réalité le les
politiques de santé sont du sport sont
des politiques de santé tout à fait et
et le fait de de faire régulièrement une
pratique sportive entretient la santé au
quotidien et aussi dans le dans le long
terme alors dans votre mission de de
charger de mission justement Desport
pour pour les diversité vous allez
organiser le 30 janvier prochain une
journée qui s'appelle tous au Vélodrome
tout à fait alors à l'initiative du
président de l'université le professeur
Alain Bui nous avons mis en place avec
en partenariat justement et sous la
coordination de Nathalie Wolf tout un
programme
pour à la fois organiser des événements
scientifique sportive et culturel dans
le but de promouvoir le sport et et à ce
titre on a l'université a dédié toute
une journée au pour célébrer le sport au
Vélodrome qui a un site olympique qui
est site olympique ilre un des grands
sites exactement où où ce jour-là cette
journée sera on aura des conférences une
table ronde mais également des activités
sportives des animations ça il y a des
animations pour découvrir des sports
exactement les sports de piste que la SC
du cyclisme et cetera et aussi il y aura
un tapis d'athlétisme sur place et donc
vraiment le sport à la fois
intellectuellement et et physiquement au
Vélodrome c'est ce jour-là vous êtes
sportif vous
si alors le sport comme je dis tout à
l'heure c'est c'est c'est vraiment un à
la fois un facteur de motivation pour
les études et ça nous permet alors comme
on le dit tous d'avoir un esprit saint
dans un corps saint et c'est voilà très
propice pour avancer dans les études
alors je vous propose on va regarder la
bande annonce de cette journée qui
s'appelle donc tous au Vélodrome et qui
a lieu le 30 janvier
merci
dans la perspective des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques 2024 l'université de
Versailles SA1 en Eveline prend toute sa
part dans cette mobilisation et organise
notamment le 30 janvier 2024 ici même au
Vélodrome national de saint-quantin en
evveline une journée intitulée tous au
Vélodrome avec le VSQ cette journée se
veut une célébration du sport et se veut
une journée festive nous invitons tous
les étudiants les personnels à nous
rejoindre ici au Vélodrome au programme
il y aura dans la la matinée un
symposium intitulé symposium sport santé
des étudiants où il y aura des
conférences une table ronde avec pour
but et bien de mettre en avant les
différentes politiques qui sont en cours
actuellement pour inciter les étudiants
à la pratique sportive dans l'intérêt de
leur santé et aussi de leur réussite les
politiques de sport sont avant tout des
politiques de santé tout au long de la
journée il y aura également des ateliers
sportifs des ateliers pédagogiques que
nous développons en partenariat avec le
vélodrome découverte de l'anneau
olympique le vélo sur piste le BMX puis
il y aura du B dance aussi parce que
vous savez c'est l'une des nouvelles
disciplines olympiques cette année puis
on aura un village olympique déployé en
partenariat avec le Comité Départemental
Olympique et Sportif des evvelines où il
y aura de l'animation tout au long de la
journée vous pouvez vous inscrire sur le
site de l'vsq les inscriptions sont déjà
ouvertes elles sont gratuites mais les
places sont limitées rejoez-nous tous
Vélodrome le 30 janvier 2024 pour
célébrer le sport et l'olympisme avec le
[Musique]
VSP
alors aabou il reste encore des des
places on peut s'inscrire encore on peut
s'inscrire encore d'accord ouais il
reste encore des places alors vous voyz
le vélodrome il est assez grand oui
alors pour les activités sur piste c'est
c'est un peu réglementé donc il faut
s'inscrire les premers inscrits seront
voilà les premiers servis mais il y a
quand même suffisamment de place pour
accueillir voilà ou t ceux qui ou vous
coup d'essayer de voir comment parce que
c'est impressionnant de rouler sur cette
sur cette piste très impressionnant une
expérience non je l'ai fait en virtuel
ce qui était assz amusant
a nul
et Nathalie vol justement puis que vous
prenez la parole il y a aussi le le
domaine de la culture qui qui est ant il
y a il y a un lien entre la culture et
le sport ben écoutez absolument et
d'ailleurs avec donc Erric azabou on
travaille vraiment de de concert bah
sport et culture c'est bah c'est c'est
lié depuis toujours je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez il y avait un passage très
beau dans dans le Banquet de pardon dans
la République de Platon on lit aussi
dans dans les lois où il est écrit que
que un homme a donné que un dieu pardon
a donné aux hommes la musique et la
gymnastique pour faire l'éducation de
leur énergie et de leur sagesse voilà
tout est dit et aujourd'hui encore
d'ailleurs dans dans la Charte olympique
actuelle hein de qui date du 17 juillet
2020 et bien on fait vraiment l'éloge de
cet alliage entre sport culture et
éducation donc c'est vraiment deux pôles
qui qui fonctionnent ensemble et c'est
comme ça qu'on a voulu travailler euh
donc à l'université avec Anaïs également
quand on a monté ses ses colloques avec
vraiment l'idée euh d'avoir des
colloques qui laissent à la culture une
place importante on a invité des
écrivains on va inviter
également des hommes et des femmes de de
cinéma donc on aura des cinésdébats oui
il y aura d'autres d'autres d'autres
colloques hein d'ailleurs voilà d'autres
colloques voilà don dont Anaïs va va
parler et puis surtout un marathon de
lecture
euh marathon de lecture donc prenez date
si vous le souhaitez ça c'est quand le 2
avril 18h à minuit tous nos étudiants le
personnel de l'université administratif
technique vont venir toute la soirée
lire des textes autour du sport autour
du dépassement de soi on a également eu
l'accord de nombreux écrivains deom
écrivs qui vont venir absolument avec
des dédicaces bref on va on va lire lire
lire et on veut que nos étudiants soient
pas seulement des bah des des super
techniciens d'excellents neurologues
psychologues asrologue avocat magistrat
mais on veut qu'auudelà de la technique
et bien il puissent comprendre le monde
dans lequel il vivent et l'art est un
est un est un domaine privilé et ça aura
lieu où et ça va avoir lieu à la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de Versailles
pour partenaire à Vera et beaucoup de
partenaires des évelines vont être
joints à nous d'accord an kinsk revenons
à ce coque comment est l'idée justement
de faire col sur le sport et le droit
alors l'idée m'a été donnée par les je
olympique qui vont être organisé en
cette année je me suis dit que c'était
l'occasion de travailler sur sur cet
objet qui est le
sport et donc j'ai voulu monter tout un
cycle de coloc qui permettent vraiment
de de
d'embrasser toutes les dimensions du
droit dans lesquelles le sport est un
objet en fait juridique et et l'intérêt
pour moi c'était certes de faire
intervenir des spécialistes du sport du
droit du sport mais aussi de demander à
des collègues qui ne sont pas
spécialistes de droit du sport
d'appréhender ce cet objet un peu
particulier qui est le sport et de
permettre d'avoir leur regard sur leur
branche du droit euh au sujet du sport
et donc c'est ça qui m'intéressait
d'avoir tout un panel comme ça de
colloque sur le droit et le sport alors
il y avait plusieurs thèmes qui étaient
abordés dans ce colloque euh on va on va
en feuilleter quelques-uns euh et on va
peut-être commencer par ce l'un des
premiers thèmes dans lequel auquel vous
participiez notamment qui s'appelle
sport et
[Musique]
inégalité c'est un des premier thème qui
était abordé avec une représentante de
la l'agente de la Défenseur des droits
hein oui euh euh Éric aabou quand on dit
sport et inégalité on se dit bah oui
mais il y a d'abord une inégalité
physique on n'est pas tous ég devant le
sport non tout à fait il Puut avoir des
inégalités d'ordre physique mais les les
les inégalités les plus préoccupantes
sont celles qui sont d'ordre sociétal
oui euh donc l'inégalité d'accès aux
équipements sportif l'inégalité euh
d'éducation de culture pour pouvoir
accéder à comprendre que le sport est
important et et et et et chercher être
en quête de de de s'en approprier euh en
dehors de ça il y a les autres
inégalités comme les les les les les
difficultés d' h en rapport avec
l'enfermement de sur soi euh comme le
dit souvent on le dit souvent il y a il
y a des gens qui sont assignés à
domicile et donc pour des raisons
sociales ne sortent pas et par
conséquent peu sociabilisé et du coup
font pas du sport et c'est ceux-là qui
ont le lourd fardeau de l'obésité et
même des problèmes psychocognitives en
rapport avec la sédentarité aussi euh
alors pour pourquoi il pourquoi cette
présence de la de la représentante de
euh de de la comment s'appelle pas
l'butsman mais de de la défenseur
l'adjointe la défenseuse des droits
effectivement avec Nathalie on s'est dit
que ce serait intéressant de pouvoir la
faire
intervenir sur la notion de
discrimination dans le sport
discrimination c'est ça hein oui
exactement euh et l'intérêt en fait
c'était justement de dépasser cette
question de l'inégalité sportive au
regard des compétences physiques
intrinsèques à la personne mais de voir
voilà de voir aussi qu'ell peuvent être
nourri par des conditions de vie
différentes par des accès différents ou
aux installations sportives et puis
essayer de voir
comment le Défenseur des droits peut
corriger aussi par son action ses
discriminations en portant son attention
sur elle nous a expliqué les questions
d'accès aux infrastructures que toutes
les populations devaient avoir accès à
ces infrastructures sans discrimination
et dans dans le dans le principe il y a
il y a un droit d'accès oui alors
effectivement elle nous a elle nous a
bien expliqué que les collectivités
publiques mettent permettent l'accès à
certaines
infrastructures et ne doivent pas
effectivement discriminer certains
certaines populations certaines
personnes en fonction du quartier
d'habitation et que normalement l'accès
doit pouvoir être être
permis et puis on a aussi des règles
juridiques qui viennent corriger
certaines tendances euh à euh faire une
distinction à instaurer des inégalités
dans le sport notamment les inégalités
entre hommes et femmes et euh et le
droit est peut-être là aussi pour
corriger euh certaines tendances
certains mécanismes qui relèvent en fait
de notre société et de voilà d'une
évolution qui n'est pas encore abouti
sur l'égalité hommes-femm et que l'on
retrouve en fait dans le sport ne
serait-ce que sur euh les équipements
sportifs euh la question de savoir
est-ce que on adapte les équipements
sportifs ou non aux femmes euh on pense
voilà par exemple à la voile avec du
matériel peut-être qui peut être alléger
pour les femmes puisque avec une masse
musculaire moins importante que celle
des hommes oui retrouve des inégalités
enfin sociales c'est c'est ça F au fond
le l'inégalité devant le sport elle est
quoi elle est elle est territoriale
souvent elle est sociét sociale oui elle
est sociale et puis euh euh sexuelle
donc du coup aussi et puis euh elle
apparaît euh des euh des l'école en fait
euh et ça on l'a bien vu lors de nos
collocques et on en a discuté euh
effectivement euh les écoliers n'ont pas
accès au même sport en fonction de leur
lieu de résidence et euh de leur lieu
euh de d'enseignement et là où se
situent l'école et évidemment quand euh
on habite dans les Alpes et bien on peut
aller faire du ski et puis euh quand on
est en région parisienne et bien en
fonction du lieu d'habitation on a plus
ou moins accès à certaines installations
sportives absolument et puis dans le sud
on fait de la pétanque voilà
ou de la voile est-ce que le bout de
l'égalité au fond entre entre les hommes
et les femmes ça sera ça sera peut-être
quand on organisera des des compétitions
mixtes oui alors il y a cette question
qui se pose effectivement ça se fait peu
et c'est dommage il y a des sport ça
pourrait alors il y a des sports où il y
a probablement des des inégalités
physiques mais il y a des sports où ça
pourrait envisager alors le sport
parfait pour ça c'est l'équitation qui
est mon sport de prédilection et
effectivement là c'est mixte tant pour
les cavaliers que pour les chevaux les
hongres et et ettalons et jument concour
ensemble et donc là il y a une égalité
parfaite dans ce sport on pourrait
peut-être s'en inspirer et encore
faut-il effectivement quand même prendre
en considération la la différence de de
capacité musculaire physiologique qui
est inévitable et puis après il y a
toutes les question savoir dans quelle
catégorie peuvent concourir les
personnes qui trans genre et donc là il
y a des il y a effectivement des
réflexions à mener comment comment
comment ça se passe pour l'instant alors
c'est très compliqué on va avoir une une
intervention dans le prochain colloque à
ce sujet qui aura lieu au mois de enfin
le trème colloque qui aura lieu au mois
de mai sur la santé et l'environnement
et une doctorante untien reviendra sur
cette question et donc elle nous
expliquera comment on peut quelle
solution on peut trouver pour l'instant
c'est très compliqué parce que les
personnes sont considérées comme devant
euh euh euh concourir dans la catégorie
qui est la leure à l'origine l'origine
c'est homme pour un homme qui devent une
femme et femme pour une femme qui vient
un homme mais mais il y a des il y a des
transges qui se considèrent ni comme
homme ni comme femme bien sû alors
est-ce qu'on va créer une une trè
catégorie euh non non mais c'est c'est
c'est vraiment enfin c'est un sujet
parce que ça montre les limites au fond
de bah de l'articulation de tous nos
droits entre eux parce que c'est ça au
fond le droit c'est d'arriver à
concilier des droits et des libertés qui
sont des exigences contradictoires on
veut plus d'égalité mais est-ce que en
créant plus d'égalité on crée pas de
nouvelle discrimination et voilà là le
juriste doit faire preuve et le juge on
verra vont faire preuve de de plus en
plus de subtilité
dans il y a eu des des procès par
exemple de de de personnes
transgenre pour participer à des
épreuves sportives oui alors il y a eu
des des décisions des un
contentieux je vais pas vous en parler
dans le détail mais effectivement il
faudra venir au
coloc on en parle parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet passionnant erabou il
y a il y a une question qui ressurgit là
beaucoup on la voit dans les
journaux avec l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques c'est au
fond est-ce que on sait que l'Angleterre
par exemple c'est un pays sportif qu' a
des pays sportif et on se demande est-ce
que la France est vraiment un pays
sportif vous avez une réponse à
ça vous essayez vous faites vous faites
en sorte que ça devienne en tout cas la
France de pas son histoire et et de par
ce qui se fait est vraiment une nation
une des grandes nations sportives du
monde même si c'est la France est
peut-être pays un pays petit en taille
si on veut mais en matière de sport le
rayonnement international du sport
français est de voilà mais parce qu' on
dit par exemple vous de le dire vous en
parliez pour l'université mais c'est
vrai pour l'éducation dans dans dans les
pays anglo-saxon c'est une matière aussi
importante que les autres l'éducation
physique en France alors c'est en train
de changer mais pendant longtemps ça a
été considéré comme voilà le truc qu'on
faisait euh 2hur par semaine exactement
en France c'est d'ailleurs l'un des l'un
des sujets que nous allons aborder lors
du symposium le 30 janvier euh il y a
aujourd'hui quelques puisqu'on a invité
des représentants de Lana stafs donc
l'Association nationale des étudiants en
staffs pour nous parler puisquils ont
fait une enquête nationale auprès des
étudiants euh représenté par 20000
étudiants pour voir euh étudier un peu
les questions de l'accidentarité mais
aussi les freins actuellement les freins
qui s'opposent à au développement du
sport universitaire français et on aura
aussi la directrice île-de-fance de la
Fédération Française du Sport
Universitaire qui interviendra aussi euh
l'objectif étant de mettre un peu en
avant ces freins là que nous avons et et
principalement en dehors de la
motivation des étudiants les freins sont
aussi au niveau des structures de
l'université comment dédier du temps à
la pratique sportive de façon bien
claire comment créer des unités
d'enseignement du sport et avec voilà de
façon incitative pour que les étudiants
puissent s'approprier euh il y a les
équipements mais aussi il faudra en face
des équipement l'état d'esprit l'état
d'esprit le changement de de mentalités
ou j'ai une intervie de Flor madouou je
crois qu' triple triple médaill
olympique il dit on n pas du tout un
pays de sport euh il dit il ont réduit à
deux les heur de de cours de PS on peut
pas dire que qu'on peut être les la
meilleure nation en mettant ces moyens
là c'est pas possible on a de très bons
talents mais il y a on n pas les
infrastructures quoi ouais je je suis à
moitié d'accord avec lui mais
effectivement il est dans son rôle on
est à un moment où il faut faire bouger
les choses donc il faut voilà là il a
fait une déclaration je pense sur le
coup de colère pour dire qu' qu' a qu' a
il a matière de se boug ou au niveau
institutionnel pour pour donner un peu
plus de temps au sport et aussi plus de
moyens au sport à l'université mais
aussi simplement dans la population mais
c'est vrai que même quand on regarde les
les les le
football les les supporters c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose en France dans
les pays angle Saxon il y a il y a quand
même des différences hein même si bon
tout ça est en train de changer mais euh
c'est vrai que la question des moyens
elle est de la volonté d'État alors je
il y a eu quand même des des je crois 10
millions d'euros qui ont été euh
consacré à la pratique sportive à
l'exercice physique c'est ce qu' annoncé
la ministre euh Mad Castera ouaa Castera
ouais et enfin qui contesté pour
d'autres choses est-ce que vous avez eu
cette polémique formidable on reproche
on dit OUI son fils a eu la trè étoile
alors qu'il aurait pas dû
a ça devient ça devient terrible euh oui
la la alors ça c'est important ça c'est
c'est au médecin que je m'adresse mais
la la pratique quotidienne du sport même
vous disiez il y a des gens qui sortent
pas mais on peut faire des exercices
chez soi c'est c'est important non
farait il faudrait tout à fait 30
minutes d'activité physique par jour par
jour ouais alors alors ça paraît
beaucoup mais en même temps c'est pas
beaucoup et ça suffit quand même pour
faire reculer pas mal de de problèmes de
santé le diabète l'hypertension et
cetera mais comme je dis tout c'est tout
ce qui est lié à la dépression à
l'anxiété bien c'est des troubles
cognitifs qui sont réglés par régulés
par le sport et pourquoi parce que
l'exercices alors il faut souligner
aussi quelque chose qu'on on en parle
pas souvent mais là il s'agit vraiment
de l'activité physique modérée mais de
façon répétée la marche à pied par
exemple marche àed ex c'est ça on a pas
besoin il a été démontré par plusieurs
études qu'on a pas besoin d'être dans de
de l'activité intensive pour avoir en
avoir les bénéfices c'est vraiment de
l'activité modéré sauf qu'il faut être
dans la régularité pourut faire rentrer
ça dans le dans la routine quotidienne
et la pratiquer tous les jours et c'est
en ça que le le le le sport rejoint
l'apprentissage rejoint la pédagogie tel
qu'on l'explique c'estàdire la
répétition produit l'effet à long terme
il faut il faut faire de la faut pas
faire un truc he et puis voilà faut pas
faire un truc intensif pendant une
semaine puis après plus rien derrière
mux faire il faut faire tous les jours
ce qu'on peut mais bien le faire et et
et le faire quotidiennement et dans la
durée bon mais ça régule tout la marche
c'est pourquoi on conseille mant d'aller
prendre son métro en allant à pied
laisser les trtinett marcher euh
voilà il y a le développement du vélo
qui est pas mal il y a le vélo aussi
tout à fait le vélo il y a il y a il y a
pas mal d'alternatives hein pour faire
du sport si on veut du sport tout en
besoin de de quelque chose d'utile si je
peux dire enfin tout à fait c'est c'est
de mettre le sport en parallèle en doit
faire entrer le sport dans notre routine
quotidienne et c'est ce qu'il faut euh
et 30 minutes ça suffit pour faire des
effets
impressionnants à long termeou c'est bon
pour la santé quoi très très bon pour la
santé peut-être qu'on peut quand même
distinguer l'activité physique et le
sport euh c'est c'est peut-être
important aussi par parce que on parle
de ça parce qu'il y a une opération
nationale dit c'était une grosse
nationale et et c'est 30 minutes
d'activité physique par ou ce qui n'est
pas du sport parce que dans le sport il
y a cette dimension de règles du jeu euh
de d'entraînement alors éventuellement
de la compétition mais surtout aussi de
l'entraînement de l'effort euh et puis
de jeux et de respect des règles et donc
et puis après il y a toutes les valeurs
qui sont véhiculées par le sport qui ne
sont pas véhiculés par une simple
activité physique toute la la question
de la loyauté du fairplay de et et donc
peut-être qu'on peut aussi disting tout
à fait ça aussi il faut distinguer alors
on est sur de la sémantique là mais dans
la réalité euh on entend en général par
Sport les disciplines sportives des
activités bien régulées ou même de
compétitions surtout le sport de haut
niveau aussi tout tout dépend à qui on
s'adresse c'est vrai que le sport
s'adresse au sportifs l'activité
physique ça s'adresse à tout le monde
c'est c'est le public qui est un peu
différent mais mais le sport peut
s'adresser à tout le monde aussi parce
que finalement on peut pratiquer un
sport sans être sportif de haut niveau
et pour autant il y a il y a quand même
cette dimension r nous qui nous
intéresse
je vous intéresse c'est l'articulation
entre les règles du jeu et les règles du
droit et tout ça c'est aussi très
intéressant pour nous juristes et donc
mais là ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que passeport le fait de
s'inscrire dans une dans un club de
sport dans une fédération pour c'est que
ça permet d'instaurer une règle on est
contraain d'y aller et quelque part
c'est pas mal une démarche mais en de
c'est ça en dehors de ça dans vie de
tous les jours nous pouvons faire de
l'activité physique sportive sans avoir
besoin de l'aide de personne euh la
course à pied la marche euh voilà et le
but c'est de tout faire pour instaurer
quand même dans ça dans sa vie cette
cette activité làà et la faire
régulièrement et c'est démontré he par
plusieurs études ça fait reculer le
diabète ça fait reculer les troubles
cognitifes Alzheimer et cetera ça fait
reculer le l'hypertension artérielle et
voilà oui donc c'est c'est absolument
nécessaire fait même même si voilà même
si on n'est pas dans une attitude
sportive au sens stri du terme il y a il
y a une commission parlementaire qui
vient de rendre un rapport assez
critique sur la sur la le fonctionnement
des fédérations sportives hein h oui oui
ce sera un thème aussi de et oui ce sera
un thème aussi d'étude alors ça ce sera
pour le colloque le prochain colloque
qui aura lieu le 26 avril à versaill
aussi mais pas au château du côté de la
mairie cette fois euh et et qui aura
pour thème sport et activités économique
et euh et effectivement on aura une
présentation sur le fonctionnement des
fédérations sportives la question de
comment les fédérations sportives
organisent en fait la pratique de le
leur sport et euh l'incidence en fait de
de de du management des fédérations
sportives sur l'entraînement des
sportifs on a des sportifs qui se sont
exprimés là-dessus notamment euh euh
Tonga euh euh pour le tennis a euh
largement critiqué la manière dont la
Fédération Française fonctionne et euh
et entraîne il y a souvent un entre soi
dans les dans les dans les fédération
c'est-à-dire et on a vu aussi euh quand
il y a eu quand il y a eu enfin dans le
patinage artistique quand quand il y a
eu bah des dirigeants qui étaient euh
qui étaient accusés d'avoir euh euh
enfin de de d'attouchement sexuel sur
des bon il y a eu des protections
terribles enfin ils étaient tous
protégés parce qu'il y avait un autre
soi quoioui oui alors là on dépasse
effectivement le simple entraînement et
effectivement il y a aussi cette
question du silence qu'on rrouve dans
d'autres domaines mais là ce silence là
effectivement qu'il faut briser pour
protéger les sportives et les sportifs
de de leurs entraîneurs de tout le staff
autour qui peut avoir une emprise
notamment sur les plus jeunes et ça
c'est vraiment en train de changer c'est
vrai oui alors Nathalie vouz ajouter
quelque chose sur les règles parce qu'on
peut-être pass au thème du un thème qui
vous est cher oui euh c'est justement le
euh le le sport et la
[Musique]
religion
alors sport et religion à priori comme
ça on se dit ça n'a rien à
voir si voilà on peut on peut se signer
parfois avant une compétition mais et
pourtant si et oui oui oui ben ça
rejoint ce que ce que ce que disait
Anaïs tout à l'heure sur la question don
des règles he parce qu'une équipe c'est
comme une mini société puis si chacun y
va ben moi le lundi je peux pas faire ça
et puis moi c'est le mardi moi c'est le
mercredi l'équipe aller à la piscine
s'il y a des garçons et ceter donc c'est
ça c'est pour que l'équipe fonctionne le
service public fonctionne il faut qu'il
y ait un minimum de de règles communes
alors c'est vrai que a priori on
pourrait se dire que et bien justement
le sport il est vecteur de on l'a dit de
VI c'est ça d'égalité il fait sauter
toutes les barrières culturelles et
linguistiques on demande pas à quelqu'un
qui joue avec vous s'il est croyant pas
croyant exactement donc on pourrait dire
c'est ça exactement et on pourrait se
dire donc c'est un rempart extrêmement
solide contre la la propagande le
prosélitisme le communautarisme voir le
le radicalisme et on se rend compte que
et bien justement au contraire le sport
est un porte-voix euh des radicalités
notamment religieuses c'est même un
miroir grossissant il y a eu pas mal
d'études récemment hein au cours des
dernières années je pense par exemple à
l'étude du Conseil d'État euh il y en a
eu plusieurs euh 2018-2019 il y a le le
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation le rapport du Conseil des
Sages de la laïcité les livres du
sociologue Hugo Micheron enfin bref euh
tous ces tous ces derniers rapports qui
nous montrent que le sport c'est
vraiment le lieu privilégié de
l'entrisme religieux mais d'ailleurs
comme l'éducation hein c'est pas c'est
sur le noir du sport d'ailleurs monttrit
ça dans les dans dans les clubs enfin
euh ou qui était souvent infiltré soit
par euh oui par des des religieux
radicaux ah oui on a des publics
vulnérables des enfants et comme comme
les l'éducation voilà c'est vraiment un
lieu privilégié pour ceux qui pour les
idéologues qui voudrai euh mettre à plat
les les principes républicains alors euh
bah les règles en France c'est assez
clair euh puisque on a un État laïque
donc ça veut dire bah d'abord la liberté
religieuse et on s'est beaucoup beaucoup
battu pour arriver à à ça ça ça a mis
des siècles de d'intolérance de massacre
donc c'est très très précieux et euh
chacun donc a la liberté religieuse les
sportifs aussi tous ceux qui font du
sport alors la liberté religieuse mais
les signes religieux par exemple il y a
eu je crois un arrêt du Conseil d'État
une décision du Conseil d'État sur le
port du voile au foot enfin de en tout
cas d'un signe religieux pour les femmes
au football oui alors donc oui la
liberté religieuse mais voilà la liberté
religieuse en France voilà elle est elle
est elle est assez particulière on a ce
qu'on appelle la laïcité à la française
donc ça veut dire que depuis 1905 il y a
la liberté de d'opinion religieuse
chacun peut croire à ce à ce qu'il veut
même changer de religion et on a aussi
la la liberté de culte collectivement
c'est ce que dit la loi 1905 et
également donc la séparation de la
sphère politique et de la sphère
religieuse donc ça veut dire que l'État
est neutre et ça veut dire dans les
services publics on a une une neutralité
qui s'impose et à l'école par exemple on
n' pas le droit d'aller nager en burkini
on est obligé de suivre un cours de PF
et cetera donc ça c'est pour les
services publics et les fédérations bah
dont on parlait à l'instant qui sont qui
sont agréé ou délégataire de service
public et bien elles peuvent dans leur
statut euh et bien interdire le port de
signe religieux la manifestation
religieuse elles ont cette libertélà et
évidemment voilà ce qui ce qui est pas
simple alors nous en France le Conseil
d'État était très clair dans l'affaire
desjabeuse il a dit voilà pas de port du
hijjab pendant les manifestations
sportives parce que ça ça ça ça empêche
le bon fonctionnement du service public
et puis ça peut créer des risques
d'affrontement et euh de confrontation
donc vous voyez il y a vraiment les deux
aspects fonctionnement du service public
et ordre public au sens euh euh au sens
large du terme donc ça c'est ce qui a
été dit euh cette année enfin il y a
quelques mois par le Conseil d'État
c'est très clair c'est aussi ce que ce
que dit euh la Charte olympique il y a
un article très clair euh l'article 50
de la Charte olympique je je vous le
cite parce que les mots sont importants
aucune sorte de démonstration ou de
propagande politique religieuse ou RAC
n'est autorisé dans un site ou un
emplacement olympique bon la Charte
olympique c'est le Comité olympique
voilà c'est ça donc la Charte olympique
voilà ce sont les règles qui qui qui
vont s'appliquent bon alors après voilà
mais alors voilà le problème c'est que
on a déjà vu par exemple tout à l'heure
des
athlètes
iranien par ex voilà qui sont voilés
enfinah voilz ENF qui ont la tête voilà
voilà un athlète iranienne danceuse de
javelot absolument voilà oui alors euh
le voilà on verra si le CIO va va
respecter la Charte olympique déjà il a
il a transgressé pas mal de fois il y a
plein d'exemples euh bah vous citiez les
les les Iraniennes par exemple en 96 à
Athènes au Gio d'athèn euh la c'est une
tireuse à la carabine c'est la première
fois d'ailleurs qu'une donc une femme
est autorisée à apportter le le foulard
islamique lors d'une d'une compétition
en 2004 le CEO transgresse sa propre
règle notamment pour des raisons
financières hein il va autoriser le le
port du hijjab avec une logique qui
consiste au fond à dire que le port du
foulard islamique est une question non
pas cultuelle mais culturelle voilà
c'est l'argument qui est souvent invoqué
c'est pas c'est pas la c'est pas la
religion au fond c'est voà exactement et
qu'on avait c'est un argument qu'on
avait retrouvé bah tout récemment ça ça
c'est ceux qui défendent le POR qui
disent le ou ou le CIO pour le pour
l'autoriser c'est ça
leutorise ou ça c'est très ambigu he
c'est très ambigu et ça nous rappelle je
sais pas si vous avez en tête il y a
quelques mois le contentieux de laba à
l'école où les associations ou disait
c'est culturel alors c'est g non elle
disait voilà elle disait c'est culturel
culturel mais en même temps et ça
c'était génial et ça montre vraiment
toute l'ambigué du sujet les
contradictions dans lesquelles sont
prises ces association là elle soulevait
quoi elle faisait elle formait ce qu'on
appelle un référé liberté donc on va
devant le juge de l'urg pour avoir très
vite la suspension d'une décision et
elles invoquaient quoi la liberté
religieuse donc elles disent c'est
culturel c'est pas culturel nom de la
libertéig vous voyez elles sont un peu
prises au propre piège de leur de leurs
argumentations je suis au championnat du
monde de football
féminin il y il y a quelques mois tout
le monde regarder l'équipe de du Maroc
parce qu'il y avait justement une
arrière arrière droite ou arrière gauche
je crois qui avait le voile voilà tout
le monde se disait ça pas les mêmes
appréhende pas la même les choses de la
même manière que la FFF en France ou
absolument on verra comment les chos
vont se passer pendant oui on va voir ce
qui va ce qui va se passer comment
seront traités bah oui par exemple les
athlètes iraniennes ouis bien sûr parce
que là oui c'est c'est il y a il y a un
dictateur on dit c'est culturel c'est
culturel c'est aussi politique hein
souvent ouais absolument tout à fait
tout à fait parce que là ça touche à
quelque chose imaginez en chaque pays P
à ces lois mais quand on tombe dans le
domaine de l'olympisme et du sport
international et bien il faut des règles
qui s'appliquent à différents pays où il
y a différentes législations et
différentes cultures religieuses et
ceteraol et la chat est là pour donner
un cadre mais on voit bien que c'est oui
il il y a des compromissions quoi des
compromis je sais pas si des compromis
ou des compromissions ENF chacun chacun
peut juger après mais en effet voilà la
charte est pas totalement
respectée au nom de euh oui au nom des
identités nationales national c'est ça
oui absolument et dans un autre domaine
même si on n'est pas dans le sport je
pensais là récemment à cette je sais pas
si vous vous rappelez c'était en 2019 à
Moscou lors du championnat de d'échec il
y avait eu cette femme iranienne
puisqu'on parle des femmes iraniennes
miltra etjasip pour elle a fait sa
compétition d'échec donc championne
iranienne elle a fait son sa compétition
d'échec en retirant son voile ouis
islamique sauf qu'elle a pas pu ensuite
retourné en Iran donc elle est exilé en
France elle vient d'avoir la nationalité
française il y a quelques mois j'ai vu
ça et évidemment elle peut pas retourner
dans son pays sinon elle risque elle
risque sa vie euh donc c'est intéressant
de voir aussi iranienne qui avait retiré
son voile voilà oui c'était avant Macha
Amini en oui oui c'était c'était un
petit peu avant ou absolument
euh Anaïs voulez ajouter quelque chose
sur ce thème non je pense qu'on a on a
bien fait le tour effectivement il y a
beaucoup de TH alors on n pas obligé
d'aller mais il y a un thème qui qui est
très intéressant je trouve c'est de le
sport et la sécurité on va parler
beaucoup pour les jou
[Musique]
oui euh c'est vrai qu'il y a un peu de
alors il y a la sécurité c'est c'est
évidemment c'est un impératif
euh total enfin pour le pour le les
organisateurs des Jeux olympiques de
Paris et ici aussi euh et on voit bien
qu'il y a deux thèses qui s'opposent au
fond ceux qui sont chargés du maintien
de l'ordre qui
sont favorables à pouvoir utiliser tous
les moyens que la technologie leur donne
pour éviter tout problème et puis ce qui
disent au nom de la la liberté
individuel non on veut pas être filmé
forcément la reconnaissance faciale
enfin tout ces tous ces objets là c'est
vrai que c'est le problème qui se pose
oui alors effectivement la la question
de la sécurité seppose dans toutes les
compétitions sportives évidemment que ce
soit les J ou la Coupe du monde de
football ou autres c'est pas une une
question nouvelle puisque elle s'est
toujours posée en revanche ce qui se
pose avec un peu plus d'acuité
aujourd'hui c'est la question
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
pour assurer cette cette sécurité et
l'incidence de cette ces nouvelles
technologie sur nos libertés et et c'est
bien cet équilibre que il faut essayer
de rechercher entre protection de
l'ordre public et puis respect de la vie
privée respect des données personnelles
euh liberté d'aller et venir et donc cet
équilibre làà effectivement il est pas
évident à trouver surtout quand on
organise une compétition mondiale qui
réunit autant de personnes euh pendant
si peu de jours finalement donc euh avec
sur des territoires différents à des
endroits euh euh différents et ça c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un c'est c'est très
complexe un adjoint à la à la sécurité
au maire de Versailles est venu nous
expliquer les enjeux pour Versailles ne
serait-ce que pour organiser le passage
du marathon et puis euh le oui il y a il
y a déjà les enjeux quotidiens hein pour
pour les gens en gros il a dit euh
prenez votre voiture et partez si vous
pouvez oui c'est ça c'est-à-dire que euh
il y a des
considérations c'est très concret
c'est-à-dire comment on permet au
marathons de passer dans les rues avec
une sécurité assurée et donc pas de
voiture qui stationne dans ces avenu qui
sont
occupés très très fortement par par les
véhicules donc c'est très très
intéressant parce que le si on prend
l'exemple des
ivelines il y a deux territoires très
différents c'est vrai que Versailles est
plutôt petite ville si je peux dire
enfin avec des des rues c'est vrai qu'il
faut il faut dégager SaintQuentin c'est
un peu un problème probablement un peu
différent je dire il a il y a plus de de
de voix d'accès de de choses comme ça le
Vélodrome et pas au milieu de de d'une
vieille ville si je peux dire et puis
c'est localisé c'est-à-dire que il y a
un bâtiment précis dans lequel les
personnes vont se rendre là le passage
du marathon sont Maron peut le faire il
faut il faut enlever les voitures il
faut de la même manière acheminer les
spectateurs au château pour pouvoir
assister aux compétitions
équestr c'est toute toute une
organisation aussi et donc effectivement
les collectivités sont quand même
confronté à à à des à des problèmes qui
leur sont finalement inédits et qui leur
seront posés sûrement qu'une fois dans
dans notre vie parce que si on voit à
peu près le cycle de de des Joos en
France et bien c'est une fois par siècle
donc donc de toute façon c'est aussi une
expérience qui va être faite une fois et
qu'on ne pourra pas rentabiliser en tout
cas sûrement pas pour les gios d'été
donc donc il faut effectivement mettre
tous les moyens en place et et découvrir
peut-être au fur et à mesure comment
comment ça va se s'organiser mais alors
je parlais des des des d'utilisation des
des moyens techniques alors il y a il y
a il y a une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui est qui est très
intéressante là-dessus sur l'utilisation
des drones et sur la la vidéo
prototection oui qui est plutôt
réticente non me semble-t-il
l'utilisation de ces ces technologies
alors surtout la question du traitement
par algorithme en fait des des des
images qui sont captées par les caméras
euh effectivement euh la la question a
été de savoir si on pouvait permettre un
tel traitement si on pouvait permettre
un traitement sans contrôle humain ou
avec un contrôle humain est-ce qu'on
pouvait permettre aux caméras
géothermiques de pouvoir filmer et donc
de détecter aussi euh finalement les
émotions la la l'état d'esprit essayer
de de comprendre l'état d'esprit dans
lequel est la personne quand quand elle
apparaît sur la caméra et donc euh donc
il y a aussi des enjeux qui sont qui se
présentent grâce à nouvell technologie
et et la crainte effectivement c'est de
se dire que si on a investi dans des
outils tels que cela euh même si on nous
promet que ce sera voilà si on nous
promet que ce sera utilisé juste
ponctuellement parce que il y a des
enjeux très spécifique de sécurité pour
les j qu'on comprend parfaitement euh le
risque c'est effectivement de pérenniser
ce type d'usage donc donc le Conseil
constitutionnel a pris une décision qui
est euh aussi de de limiter euh cette
l'utilisation de et le traitement de par
algorithme de des images qui seront
captées pendant les Jeux olympiques mais
vous avez raison de dire que
probablement si c'est si c'est autorisé
ça va pas s'arrêter les retours en
arrière les retours on les connaî pas
dans ce genre de ça et puis on a on a
bien vu pendant la crise sanitaire aussi
que avec les covid trac tous les
contrôles qu'on avait les QR Code A
l'identité on a dû faire bouger pas mal
le droit pour voilà et donc les
protections des des des des les
protections individuelles de posent
problème actuellement et avec les Goos
ça va continuer à s'élargir c'est h
c'est c'est un Nathalie c'est c'est vrai
que c'est un un problème qui ressur il a
raison c'est vrai que le le le covid a
fait ressurgir cette cette question de
du contrôle d'un côté de de la liberté
individuelle de l'autre euh et et j'ai
l'impression que céit quelque chose
peut-être auquel on on pensait pas trop
jusqu'à présent qui qui redevient un
problème essentiel oui absolument c'est
ce qu' montré rit le le le la covid à à
et l'État d' et les deux états d'urgence
d'ailleurs contre le terrorisme et
contre la pandémie qui qui sont des
nécessités qu'on qu'on comprend tout à
fait des avec des risques très très
importants pour pour pour le la sécurité
au sens large du terme mais euh qui ont
fait qui ont repoussé au fond hein euh
les limites de ce que l'on considérait
comme étant acceptable et c'est ça aussi
et notre rapport aux nouvelles
technologies on voit cette servitude
volontaire vers laquelle chacun se jette
en donnant toutes ces données oui déjà
avec les réseaux sociaux souvent voilà
les gens qui donnent tous les détails
sur leur vie privée en disant après
comment on attend à ma vie privée mais
on attend à ma vie privée il donne tous
les tous les tout les détails sur les
réseaux sociaux déjà enfin bon c'est ça
et seulement et c'est ça c'està-dire
qu'on ce sont des données qui sont
transmis m pas seulement à
l'état ce qui est nouveau voilà mais
aussi à des entreprises des grandes
entreprises les
gfam qui sont pas soumises aux mêmes
règles que que Cell auquell l'État est
soumis et qui pose encore d'autres
questions ou donc c'est pas seulement la
surveillance de l'état mais c'est aussi
la surveillance de ces grands groupes
auquel nous sommes
tous c'est leur gagne grand group
d'avoir le plus de données précises sur
les individus
qui se servent deux non oui oui et puis
il faut il faut trouver une
proportionnalité en fait dans les moyens
qu'on va mettre en place euh parce que
on peut pas sous prétexte d'organiser
des Jeux Olympiques développer des
moyens qui portent fortement atteinte à
nos libertés donc il va falloir trouver
un équilibre un équilibre et ça ça va
dépasser le le l'enjeu des j hein mais
mais mais le le moment des JO est
évidemment très important sur sur ce
thème euh autre thème peut-être le le
dernier malheureusement parce que mais
mais qui est qui est qui est passionnant
c'est celui des des rapports du sport et
de la politique des J et de la politique
[Musique]
oui c'est la question
géopolitique Nathalie au
fond le le
moment de de naissance de de ce cette
question du rapport des des des du sport
et de la politique dans dans l'époque
moderne en tout cas c'est les Jeux
Olympiques de Berlin en 36 oui oui oui
pense que c'est vraiment un tournant
même siondate oui c'est vrai même si dès
le départ de toute façon le lien entre
Jo et politique il est il est là parce
que rien que le fait d'organiser les j
au fond c'est une démarche politique
alors elle est elle est louable
évidemment elle est très louable
puisqueil s'agit d'instaurer la paix
internationale donc déjà en soi c'est
c'est déjà
politique donc la politique oui oui est
partout même je crois en 1896 on avait
eu déjà le boycot de l'Empire ottoman
parce que les je se passai à Athène et
qu'on est en voilà on a des grosses
tensions entre ottomain et la Grèce
voilà la Chine qui va qui va boycotter
aussi la République de Chine populaire
parce que Taiwan a été reconnu par par
le COO je crois que c'est dèsès la dès
les années 50 bon de toute façon c'est
c'est c'est présent et puis bien sûr 36
c'est le tournant et pendant 36 faut
dire c'est les Jeux de Berlin jeux berin
Hitler au pouvoir voir et et et
évidemment il y a il y a il y a des
débats dans dans dans dans les pays et
et vous avez le Liv de Pierre Assouline
qui s'appelle le nageur et Pierre
assouine raconte qu'en France par
exemple il y a eu un débat est-ce qu'il
faut participer ou pas aux Jeux
olympiques et il y a un jeune député qui
se lève qui a 25 ans et qui dit non il
faut PASF c'est c'est c'est un
déshonneur de participer d'aller d'aller
au Jeux Olympiques de Berlin et c'est
c'est le jeune Pierre madas franceent
oui c'est ça mais c'est le seul et c'est
le seul se c'est vrai que la question du
boycot elle se pose tout de suite hein
très vite mais finalement il y a très
peu de boycott en réalité de C BO et il
y a même cette cette histoire incroyable
c'est que la délégation américaine des
deux grands sprinterurs deux premiers
sprinters de la délégations américaines
sont des Juifs et Hitler dit pas
question que des Juifs participent au J
il puissent gagner médaille d'or et les
Américains acceptent les Américains
acceptent et c'est comme ça que le
fameux Jess Owen euh vient remplacer
bien l'un des des deux Juifs qu'on a
prié de de de pas participer et va
devenir aussi célèbre aussi célèbre ouou
et c'est d'ailleurs c'est un c'est une
sorte de clin d'œil de de l'histoire
puisque c'est
c'est un athlète noir quil un athlète su
ce qui pour Hitler est une sorte
d'humiliation absolu he ex absolument
d'ailleurs il part du il part du stade
hein dans la victoire de Wen il remettra
plus les pieds enfin c'est c'est donc là
c'est c'est les mon fondateur oui pardon
comment dit l'on des S çaou alors alors
queexlique bien en fait il il fut même
pas attention à ça puis qu'ils veulent
pas des deux premiers on prend les deux
qui ont le temps d'après c'est pas c'est
pas du tout un calcul il veut pas ah il
veut pas de mettre non pas du tout c'est
pas même pas un calcul politique c'est
c'est juste un calcul sportif quand même
incroyable et c'est vrai que que Pierre
a souigne le monte très bien parce qu'il
a écrit un livre dont on dont on a parlé
la dernière fois puisque Pierre
Assouline a pu participer à notre
colloque on a pu l'interview et il a
écrit cette histoire qui est qui est
passionnante du du nageur très célèbre
qui s'appelle Alfred Nakache Alfred
nakach c'est donc un champion de
natation français il gagne donc
championnat de France Europe il devient
recordman du monde he c'est un
spécialiste de la nage papillon c'est
voilà brass papillon pardon et euh et
alors il est il il a participé au JO de
36 va il a été pour faire vite pardon il
a été déporté ensuite à Witz dénoncé par
un probablement par un autre nageur qui
était qui était
collaborateur et il va reparticiper
c'est cela qu' a sorte de de force
incroyable il va reparticiper à aux Jeux
Olympiques suivant quoi oui oui parce
qu'il réussit il fait partie des très
rares ESCAP il a même fait la marche de
la mort ussi à à faire partie des des
rares escapés
d'wit du renwald alors que sa femme et
sa fille et le livre est passionnant
justement sur cette période bah de de de
l'avantgerre et de la guerre évidemment
et de et de des camp de desamp des camp
de la mort mais euh et et justement du
rapport du sport avec avec cette
politique là à ce moment-là quoi oui
c'est ça c'est c'est vrai que Pierre
assouine montre très bien ça cette
période de l'Occupation et à travers le
sport voilà il nous montre comment sport
est politiques sont sont sont sont sont
absolument des liens indéfectibles et
qu'on va retrouver plus tard en 68 à
Mexico quand on va retrouver oui pendant
la guerre froide
beauoup c'est là qu'il y a des quand
c'est en gros quand c'est aux États-Unis
les Russes boycottent et quand c'est en
Russie les Américains n'y vont pas en
gros c'est ça
mais et puis après ça alors on a
tendance à penser que ça se ça se calme
une fois la chute du Mur de de
et la fin du communisme c'est pas tout à
fait le cas non on va avoir en 68 les
les deux athlètes noirs qui qui vont
lever le point au moment de recevoir les
les médailles et qui d'ailleurs donc
pour lutter contrefin dénoncer la la la
ségrégation raciale aux États-Unis qui
d'ailleurs seront bah sanctionnés hein
d'ailleurs ils seront évincés ensuite
des jeux pour ne pas avoir respecter bah
le ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure le
principe de neutralité révolutionnaire
tout à fait euh on trouve encore des
tentatives hein d'ailleurs de de boycott
mais en
réalité je pense par exemple au à la
dernière Coupe du Monde de de football
on avait eu plus ou moins les Norvégiens
si je me trompe pas je connais pas très
bien en foot mais qui était déjà déjà
plus qualifié qui avait tenté de il les
question de de
l'homosexualité qui était au enfin qui
qui avec des des discours très très
homophobe de dirigeant catarien et et il
y a eu toute la oui toute la la
discussion est-ce qu'il faut se
mobiliser ou pas est-ce qu'il faut
porter un brassard qui montrerait que on
napprouve pas ce que disent les catarien
finalement on pas finalement les les
véléités ont très vite été mis à leur
place ouais c'est un peu ça leçon
générale je sais pas si on peut tirer
une parce que ça dépend aussi des
circonstances mais mais souvent au fond
les les bah les les les dictatures ou ou
les les pouvoirs fort s'en sortent plus
plutôt bien non face au sport trouvez
pas il y a un culte de toute façon du
corps et de la puissance dans dans les
dictature dans les états la mobilisation
contre eux se fait relativement peu sauf
dans les cas de boycott proprement dit
mais oui après on peut comprendre aussi
que les sportifs certes sont
ambassadeurs de leur pays lorsqu'ils se
déplacent pour une compétition mais ce
sont des ambassadeurs sportifs et non
pas des ambassadeurs politiques et donc
on peut comprendre que il nit pas
forcément envie d'être soumis à des
considérations politiques et de devoir
porter une parole qui n'est peut-être
pas la leure et et mais pour autant ils
n'ont peut-être pas la liberté de de
s'exprimer et donc le retour au pays
peut être un peu difficile donc on p à
l'Ukraine et la
russieid l'Ukraine avait menacé de de
boycotter si jamais la Russie était
invitée on a trouvé une solution qui est
un peu c'est ça avec le drapauy puisque
les les les athlètes russes pourront
venir mais sans sans se battre sous le
oui son laun faç neutre c'est c'est vrai
que c'est mais c'est parce que c'est le
problème que vous posez c'estàd que
est-ce qu'on doit s'en prendre aux
sportifs pour faire payer la politique
de de l'État auquel ils appartiennent fa
ça ça après il faut peut-être distinguer
les sportifs qui ont soutenu
ouvertement leur voilà leurs dirigeants
et et on a vu hein des sportifs
notamment en Formule 1 sanctionné écarté
pour cela et puis et puis les sportifs
qui eux ne se sont pas exprimés et qui
s'entraînent aussi parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que cette compétition là elle
a lieu tous les 4 ans c'est un objectif
de toute une vie et donc on ne participe
à des Joos que deux trois fois dans sa
vie de sportif et donc voilà après ça
dépend des sport mais effectivement
c'est c'est quand même important de
comprendre que c'est un objectif dans
une vie ou toute l'ambiguité réside dans
le fait que on participe en général aux
compétitions internationales parfois
dans pour chaque pays dans une démarche
aussi patriotique parfois il y a
certains états l'athlète étant
représenté sous son de la peau il y a il
y a toujours un aspect patri de
patriotisme qui exactement qui qui qui
qui prend part à ce Tru là euh et qui
fait que entre euh ce que représente
l'athlète lui-même et son état et ben il
y a il y a a il y a un flou flou on va
bien le voir avec les les les athlètes
israéliens parce que il risquent il y a
des pays qui risquent de de côté s'il y
a jamais un match enfin contre de foot
je sais pas peu importe contre l'équipe
israélienne mais ils ont été boycottés
de toute façon depuis tout le temps les
Israéliens par certains pays par
certains joueurs ou
pays avant avant même là la guerre du
mois
d'octobre on voit récemment des joueurs
refuser de rencontrer des footballeurs
israéliens non mais ça ça va être ça va
être un des un des aspects qu'il va
falloir observer évidemment et et là
encore oui c'est c'est le lien entre la
la politique et et le sport oui c'est
vrai que oui on pourrait dire qu'il y a
deux ambitions différentes il a les amb
l'ambition de sportif que vous dites
c'est c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est
l'épreuve de leur vie et puis l'ambition
nationaliste des dirigeants qui est de
récupérer pour l'image de leur pays
exactement et et les pays comme la Chine
les États-Unis c'est beaucoup de ça moi
qui ai vécu quelques années en Chine on
voit bien que c'est c'est une affaire
nationale quand ce genre de compétition
ah oui ouais et oui d'honneur aussi pour
la nation d'honneur c'est ça de
patriotisme c'est l'occasion euh de de
voilà de s'affirmer à l'international à
travers ces compétitions qui normalement
sont des jeux on l'a vu par le passé
avec les les les nageuses des pays de
l'Est euh qui étit alors pour coup d'pé
hein on peut dire ça enfin dopé pas dopé
il y avait mê prêt à tout et voilà euh
pour pour pour gagner parce que c'était
C C l'image de leur pays qui était qui
était derrièreou oui une pression aussi
sûrement des dirigeants pour ramener des
médailles et sûrement justifier aussi
certaines politiques dans certains pays
on sait qu'en Chine il y a une politique
très forte
sur de développement des infrastructures
et cetera et puis c'est sûr que eux ils
font pas que 2 heures de sport par jour
à l'école enfin par semaine à l'éple à
l'école le PS un peu représenter
voilà merci beaucoup merci merci à tous
les TR la suite alors 30 janvier tous au
Vélodrome tout à fait et puis le le le
prochain colloque alors le prochain
colloque le 26 avril le vendredi donc à
Versailles du côté de la mairie et puis
les deux autres donc ce colloque là ce
sera sur les activités économiques et
puis les deux autres sur la santé et
l'environnement et le dernier au mois de
juin qui aura lieu euh sûrement on
l'espère à Paris et qui porte sur les
normes et la justice voilà juste avant
les Jeux voilà juste avant le le
marathon de l'cture Marathon venez lire
la lecture notre souffle voilà quelle
date 2 avril 18h minuit voilà on vous
attend pour lire absolument il se passe
toujours quelque chose à
l'université en des murs de l'université
même merci à tous les trois
[Musique]
beaucoup